today we are playing among us for one
hundred thousand dollars we have corpse
pewdiepie dream jacksepticeye cycuno
tommy and if i forgot your name you
probably hate me we're playing with one
imposter and if that imposter gets a dub
they get one hundred thousand dollars
so all you have to do is win and we'll
get a hundred thousand this is crazy not
only is a hundred grand on the line but
i'm playing with pewdiepie
wow a hundred thousand dollars looks
like everyone's grouping up together
let's just hop in this vent i want to
win 100 000. what would i do with a
hundred thousand dollars i think i'd
feed myself
[Music]
a lot of food are you kidding me
why did i go to electrical to begin with
i think that's my fault you're coming
with me
i can save myself a hundred grand if i
don't mess up i just gotta remember
where everyone is now they're gonna
catch me
i hope not oop sakuno don't kill me
and nobody has found my body oh
guys one hundred thousand dollars is on
the line it's in the top right of
electrical well where is everybody chris
was on the right side
sakuno where did you come from um i did
my scan in med bay and then i went to do
the lasers
okay it looks like secuno killed
quackity with a
plunger oh god we got caught already uh
i said we all skip no one has any
definite evidence just so everyone knows
i'm sitting on camps
it's either cycuno or jimmy i think that
was a vent kill
let's run all the way around we have 10
seconds left on our kill cooldown
oh my god look at it
you know what i'm gonna die aren't i
where are you going carl
you can't run from me carl you're not
muted i know that of course
no is it felix come on i think he might
be
imposter if carl dies i look really bad
that might be funny
so i'm pretty sure dream knows we have
to oh
oh my god that was the worst kill
i was very afk that round corpse where'd
you find the body bottom left engine
so who else was there saikuno after he
murdered him
i i did just pass by there yeah
here we go here's how we saved me a
hundred thousand dollars if you don't
want to screw me out of hundred grand
let's just vote tycoono or corpse and
then vote the other next round
i vote corpse i think it's sakuna i
already voted corpse i voted for saikuno
you know what i'm gonna vote myself
what what what wait 300 iq
wait corpse i voted for myself too can
we not i have a hundred grand on the
line
that's how deep my love runs look at him
come on get him out of here
i have a hundred thousand dollars in
line so i couldn't you're not get away
with anything
pick corpse or cycuno someone just pick
nobody say anything out loud
just vote well look i gotta vote for
myself again worst case scenario jimmy
loses a hundred grand
you know it's a hundred thousand dollars
is nothing it's all jokes i'll just vote
for corpse
oh god you guys actually killed him if
it's not him it's icuna
don't you dare talk about cicuna like
that oh oh
i'm the imposter and i voted to skip for
him
stop let it play out let it play out
what no
bro you just want to win 100k mr beast
ah just vote saikuna then you can go
full degenerate mode don't worry seikuno
just skip it'll be okay
no does a hundred grand mean nothing to
you idiots
you call me an idiot looks like
someone's getting annoyed
i hate these guys i hate them i hope
sakura wins now i hope psycho wins
oh he got me it's that kuno it is sakuno
i
let him get a chance to defend himself
oh hey guys i
alright it's ikea wait you can't report
the body if it's
you prices averted thank god okay
since no one won the 100 grand we're
gonna do one more game
good luck thank god it's not me oh looks
like we're not imposter so uh
a hundred thousand dollars is so much
money let's just stick with some other
people
you know what should i just stick with
big q arcade then here's tommy hello
hey oh
come on okay of course it's coral
it was that electrical who did it oh i
think i know who it was
i saw chris go into electrical and i was
stood with um big hue
and then immediately after i saw corpse
go down and into electrical and then
he's reported the body wait so who do
you think it is tommy i think it's
corpse
a self report that'd be pretty bold for
the cause
where were you he said i came down i
didn't even come down i ran from the
right
corpse if it is you don't kill me okay
it's not right
we'll give you a hundred thousand
dollars if you don't kill me can we vote
cops
no i mean to be fair there's only one
imposter like we could we might as well
yeah now now i'm sure corpse hates one
hundred thousand dollars
oh no i love this because you'll know
it's not me right away
oh god you guys you guys actually killed
him you guys said to kill him
if it's not him we just stripped him out
of a hundred dollars hundred 100 000
oh my god all right i guess corpse was
not imposter
okay i made him i made a wrong call all
right i'm really sorry corpse
tommy's an actual jerk this is why i
hate children
i have a feeling it's quackity it's
probably jimmy or carl
who to walk out of kill
it was so obviously carl
damn he's marinating where was it
alright so it's an admin
and i'm pretty sure i know who it is but
i'm not a hundred percent sure
carl where were you i'm with jimmy yeah
carl was with me for quite a while the
thing is cycuno
is is like sitting afk at the top of
cafeteria my computer was broken today
so i had to set
up my other computer in the last slide
that sounds like a 500 iq voice first of
all jimmy don't you dare
threaten cycuno yes thank you all right
just for that
i'm throwing a vote seems a little bit
irrational there he told me don't you
dare but you know it's not me right
because i was
i think it's either carl or cycuno i'm
voting carl i'm voting cycuno
actually vote carl wait carl stood up
for me i know but if it's either me or
you i mean
carl said to vote saikuna what do you
mean he stood up for you guys there's a
hundred thousand dollars on the line
what are we doing
voted himself to tie the vote thank you
seikuno carl stood up for me so it
wouldn't feel right to vote him off
there
i don't know why they think it's me or
carl though
oh this is so tough i think it's carl oh
god this isn't looking good
you'll be so scared of the green man i'm
scared of the green man i'll stick with
seikuna my
my tasks are done it's like oh no you
want to kill me on the vent they didn't
vent
one of them there one of them was trying
to get a kill here
too much pairing i'm but a man please
don't be cycuno no
say it isn't so but also i hope you win
it's carol he was right we should have
voted him
oh oh my jimmy's gonna find it
it's at the door of electrical who was
right here who was right here oh man i
just passed by there
wait who just walked by right there who
was just there it's not tommy
it's not me mr beast i don't think it is
i was there with you just so you know
the lights are fixed you can tell
they're fixed i just fixed them
you you haven't said much my among us
isn't making any noises like that's
weird i can hear you guys in discord
though
try going in and out of the vent tommy
and quackity were off to the side with
me none of us killed him i
saw you towards the end of the game
though jimmy you weren't with us for
most of the time
i actually kind of trust it's not jimin
tommy and quackity this this is what i
say
jack cleared me jack is now dead could
not have been me i
trust fully tommy and quackity therefore
if we stick together we can just vote
out the other three
i i honestly think it's sakuno no i
swear it's the sound issues he's got too
many coincidental things i've
missed a beast why me i was with you you
idiot
okay so it was actually the sound issues
um
i'm starting to think it's dream fake
vouching
he tried to manipulate us
what are they doing i was literally with
them there's 100 on the line tommy stop
being stupid
no no oh my gosh it's called i
flipping called it wow this is quite
unfortunate but i don't blame them it
was very very suspicious
oh my goodness it's quite a lot of money
it's carl it is carl wait jimmy okay be
honest who's lying
everyone listen to me i was literally
with you and quackity last round
when that body was killed i couldn't
have killed last round carl and me were
standing beside dream he slaughtered him
and i reported it i just don't
understand how jimmy got away for the
first two round kills
you have undeniable proof that it's not
me it's not undeniable proof
guys guys guys if we just skip now and
stick together because me and big you
can vouch we skip now we skip now no
no you don't skip now carl
tommy it's a 50 50 or you can skip i'm
gonna vote carl i'm gonna vote carl
no don't vote call for five seconds stop
being stupid
oh they're going to throw their world's
idiots i don't know because if all of us
stick together all of us stick together
you
idiots you impossible it's either a 50
50. you guys don't don't throw this game
my brain cannot comprehend the logic
here
oh wait now we have to split up
oh no no wait wait guys you gotta go for
the emergency
it's carl it's called it's gg's right uh
he's trying to split us
come on
no chance he did it what tommy i am
never talking to you again
i think it was clear from the beginning
i'm not that good at this game
what was that carl congratulations
you won 100
a god among men if only dream had any
suspicion